a lot of the money that comes down for  urban heat island is actually goes to  public lands  and they have money for public lands uh  parks trails  natural areas streetscapes but we want  to plant in yards we want to plant on  the south and west side of homes  to reduce energy bills which saves water  and so we're looking for that kind of  funding that goes to private because at  the end of the day  at the end of the month  there's no light island in people's  budget for a 200 tree  and  the water you know 15 gallons so that's  like one shower every couple weeks  do that  and i'm also asking if you'd help us  with indot because i-15 and 95 are big  polluters and a lot of the trees that  they put in in the very beginning when  they built it they're gone  and they need to upgrade their  irrigation so that we can keep what we  have  and they need to plant evergreens